my next guest is steamed just by my
intro dan bongino fox news contributor
one of the owners of parlor by the way
and host of the dan bongino
podcast one of the most successful in
the country dan
what mr cook forgot to say is that he
says he warned parlor
yeah the morning like an hour before he
took you guys off
and everybody else joined in that
interview disturbed me more than any
other with chris wallace what about you
yeah i mean listen uh he basically tried
to wipe us out remember it was apple
who initiated this whole thing they were
the first ones to reach out to us
on friday what was it two weeks ago and
say hey listen you guys basically have
24 hours to clean this up and he's by
the way brian his definition of
free speech is fascinating i mean you
summed it up
nicely by pointing out twitter but he
was pointing out a couple of of posts on
parlor
but he ignores the assassinate donald
trump
uh a trend on or or hashtag on on
twitter
what about all the antifa and blm groups
on twitter that
organized riots that were burned down
american cities on twitter
listen tim cook is not speaking about
principles
because if his principles were hey
parlor we took you down because we don't
allow
any incitement to violence anywhere on
any neutral platform
and we're going to take down twitter too
yeah we may have a tough legal fight but
that's not what he did
he let 18 antifa blm kill donald trump
trend on twitter no problem at all
brian not even a word about it and then
because parlor happens to attract some
conservatives
he goes after parlor starts this whole
then basically wipes the company
from the face of the earth where are you
i mean really dan i
hear you guys are coming back i saw
before i hopped on the air i was able to
get you on a website
so are you back are you on your way yeah
we have a landing page up now we should
be fully functional hopefully soon it's
been a nightmare i mean amazon aws shut
us down
um too again that brian i can't say this
enough behind the scenes it's a thousand
times worse
everyone from payment processors app
apple started a disaster for us
phone verification companies lawyers
everyone and and just to be clear
because i know there were some
you know liberals out there who
magically just found free speech
remember this is the bait decay crowd
who magically just found free speech
again and loves the constitution
like oh these are private companies are
they really oh let me give you an
analogy if you're a liberal
um when aoc and ro khanna and other
democrats out there
go on twitter and tweet about aws wiping
parlor from the face of the earth
an imparler gets wiped off the face of
the earth by aw
aws is that a private company or are
they acting on behalf of government
actors what about this
what about if they put out a law
tomorrow that said listen
if you're a conservative and you don't
believe in abortion you can go block an
abortion clinic and we're going to
immunize you from lawsuits
what if the government passed a law all
of a sudden liberals big wait wait wait
wait wait
you can't do that you can't do that but
it's
when it comes to parlor and section 230
and using private companies to act on
behalf of government actors
then they don't care then they're
private companies all of a sudden but
but dan they don't have to play this out
do you believe
it stops at the democratic party do you
believe the tech companies say they're
in power
i'm playing that card and we believe
what they believe anyway
or do you think this is going to come
out at them
listen i think this is going to end very
poorly for all these companies i think
you're going to see
now a litany of state legislation uh
that by the way i don't know whether
that breaks up these monopolies or what
do they refuse to do business i don't
know what it's going to be
but i can tell you in 2022 and i mean i
don't want to go so far out as 2024
but in 2022 i think the two big issues
are going to be election integrity
and the big tech monopolies and i don't
think they're going to like what's
coming their way because
legislation of course of speaking about
legislation
because people are just done with this
they're finished with it they know
what's going on
it's all a wink and a nod it's all phony
and it's all fake
uh we don't like incitement to violence
either do we on parlor
we have terms of service that prevent it
can you read
just go to the terms of service and then
they send us an apple an email i'll give
you a little inside baseball
apple sent us an email brian saying
you're responsible for
everything on your site no we're
responsible for our site
but we're not responsible for everything
like a product
you're asking us to be a publisher which
would violate
the law section 230. it's our site we're
responsible for keeping a decency
we're not responsible for every word
we're not the new york times
if brian kilmeade wants to put a parlor
post up he doesn't send it to me as one
of the owners and go dan
can you vet this right it's a platform
but it's good kind of knowing one of the
owners to be honest
should i have a problem when falling out
he's got a hook on the inside yeah it's
kind of good
i'm not really an insider velvet rope
guy uh i got to bring it to another area
of your expertise and that's law
enforcement
listen to congressman steve cohen you
know the guy that eats fried chicken
on the uh on the house floor oh yeah
the guard is 90 some odd percent
i believe male uh
only about 20 of white males voted for
bible
they're probably not more than 25 of the
people that are there protecting us who
voted for biden the other 75 percent
are in the class that would be uh the
large class of folks
who might want to uh do something so it
does concern me
so they're vetting everybody in the
national guard because most of them
voted for trump and they feel they might
turn
turn to the trump side and i guess blow
their security apparatus and go after
joe biden
at the inaugural is that a fair worry
brian i spend over a decade of my life
in the secret service in four years in
the nypd ah you know news flash here a
lot of law enforcement folks
happen to be conservative but you know
how many sleepless nights my wife and
kids spent at home
when i was out in the road in indonesia
and afghanistan with barack obama
a president by the way shared nothing in
common with politically
do you know how many other guys probably
in the secret service
the fbi who helped us other treasury
agents as we should call him ota
who probably helped in our security plan
were conservative who had never once in
their lifetime
entered their mind other than to keep
him and his family safe because that's
what we do in a constitutional report so
you would have taken a bullet for
president obama even though you didn't
vote for him
do you believe that in a way this
horrible incident from two weeks ago
last wednesday
they're using as an excuse to say
trump's supporters can't be trusted
of brian of course these are genuinely
awful human beings i mean between what
happened with the tech tyrants
and their abuse of this horror show that
happened on january 6th
a bipartisan condemned disaster that
nobody is like hey that was no one
everybody's condemning this thing
there is no there are no principles at
stake we all agree it was terrible
everybody get that everyone hands down
period full stop
there's no debate so why are you turning
it into a politic what are you debating
who are you you're not debating me that
was wrong at the capitol yeah you're
100 correct what are you debating the
answer is you're not
you're making cheap politics out of it
yes to attack trump supporters
and people like me unlike steve cohen
who actually put my caboose on the line
to protect barack obama and his family
and i did it proudly
and you know what i do it again because
that's what we do in the secret service
it's not a third world republic
and condemning our national guard folks
because of the color of their skin
like they can't do their job they raise
their right hand and swore to protect
the constitution
don't insult them like that but
politicians that's what they do
that's why they're politicians and they
don't have real jobs thanks for being
the first guest on uh prime time dan
fired up that was pretty awesome
that was thank you that's why people
double click on your podcast he's got a
lot to say a lot of facts
about it he texted me and said come on i
said i can't turn kill me down are you
kidding
right